[Musik]
mit joghurt und erdbeeren
damit wäre die yogurette sebastian weiß
was wirklich drin steckt frischer
joghurt und auch frische erdbeeren sucht
man in liebes riegel nachbau vergebens
sebastian lege weiß was mit den
erdbeeren passieren muss bevor sie in
der creme füllung landen in seiner
werkstatt fährt er große geschütze auf
für den intensiven geschmack hat ferrero
in pfiffigen trick parat
und wenn man die richtigen apparaturen
parat hat dann ist das super einfach
pflege beginnt simpel und schneidet die
erdbeeren in gleich dicke scheiben so
lässt sich das obst besser verarbeiten
im gefrierschrank wartet minus 200 grad
kalter stickstoff auf die erdbeeren hier
frieren sie blitzschnell ein das spart
zeit und damit geld man kann sich nicht
nur einem herd die finger verbrennen
sondern auch im shop frosta läuft
apa das nenne ich mal gefroren
[Musik]
wir müssen jetzt schnell sein kurzer
check richtig gut gefahren
im tief gefrorenen zustand gibt
sebastian läge die erdbeeren in einen
vakuum trockner der angeschlossene
generator entzieht in nur wenigen
sekunden die luft aus dem blick die
glasbehälter es entsteht ein vakuum
nun bauen die erdbeeren nicht wie üblich
auf aus ice wird unter vakuum kein
wasser sondern gas die erdbeeren
trocknen aus werden poor ich und größer
nach 24 stunden sind sie fertig
für gute ergebnisse braucht man halt
zeit fiel schon ganz gut aus
dann liege erlöst die erdbeeren aus dem
vakuum intensiv krass ziel erreicht
sebastian hat den erdbeergeschmack mit
dieser methode konzentriert sein damit
er trocknet haben die erdbeeren viele
vorteile
sie lassen sich sehr einfach fein
zerkleinern sind lange haltbar und in
der creme füllung bestens zu dosieren
ähnlich macht es wäre auch mit einer
weiteren wichtigen zutat der yogurette
frische joghurt für zu kompliziert zu
verarbeiten und das produkt ist ja auch
ungekühlt im regal hier stecken auch
vize für wasser drin
deswegen haben wir joghurt pulver das
pulver gibt sebastian lege zum erdbeer
granulat
danach folgen die hauptbestandteile der
creme zucker und fett
damit jeder wissen wirklich immer gleich
schmeckt benötigt er noch die eine
absolute geheim zu tat noch nicht
wirklich intensiv genug richter nicht
nach joghurt und auch noch nicht genug
nach erdbeere
jetzt kommt der gaumen zauber ein paar
tröpfchen aroma und wir denken wir
liegen im erdbeerfeld 12345 tropfen
reicht richtig gut aus ferrero wirbt auf
yogurette verpackungen großflächig mit
erdbeeren und joghurt setzt aber nur
wenig davon 1
das ist legal in einem riegel stecken im
schnitt nur ein halbes gramm erdbeeren
für den geschmack sorgt ein
synthetisches clever ausgetüfteltes
aroma auf erdbeeren und joghurt muss es
nicht passieren
durch diesen trick schmecken yogurette
riegel immer gleich und intensiv
[Musik]
ehrlich gesagt
die limette das original
des schneidens durch
läge original es hat funktioniert
sebastian weges regel kommt dem original
optisch ziemlich nahe
der geschmack ist schwerer zu kopieren
ferrero setzt spezielle künstliche
aromen ein die jedem produkt den
typischen und unverwechselbaren ferrero
geschmack verleihen
das unternehmen spart so an teuren
zutaten und sorgt mit diesem trick
trotzdem für einen außergewöhnlichen
geschmack
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fast alle beliebten süßigkeiten werden
deshalb kopiert supermarkt- und
discounter-ketten haben günstige
nachahmer im sortiment zum beispiel die
yogurette die zutatenlisten von marke
und kopie gleichen sich auf den ersten
blick doch gilt das auch für den
geschmack das bild sebastian läge in
berlin heraus finden 20 tester von jung
bis alt lädt er ein
ob wir den klassiker zu der alternative
raus schmeckt viel spaß und ab in die
genussvolle in seinem check lässt
sebastian läge die tester blind
verkosten
denn es soll nur der geschmack sehen auf
dem prüfstand steht ein echter klassiker
wie yoga rente
[Musik]
den riegel lässt der produktentwickler
im geschmacks duell gegen den chocolat
erdbeer joghurt riegel von penny
antreten
die marke kostet satte 80 prozent mehr
schmeckt sie auch besser zwischen den
beiden proben neutralisieren die tester
mit wasser und brot ihre geschmackssinne
am ende müssen sie sich entscheiden
welches produkt schmeckt ihnen besser
[Musik]
tatsächlich überzeugt das markenprodukt
und zwar deutlich 90 mögen es lieber als
die neue variante hat ferrero im
vergleich vielleicht besonders viele
gute zutaten für yogurette verarbeitet
das möchte sebastian lege aufdecken
naja ist fan der yogurette und kennt das
produkt genau er mal ein kleines video
experimentier aufgebaut ja was meinst du
denn wie viel joghurt und erdbeeren in
einer ganzen packung stecken
88 gramm joghurt mainz sowie ok sowie
für erdbeeren ich denke sie zehn prozent
sondern sind zwölf viel zu viel nicht
mal eine ganze erklärt
[Musik]
was passt in 125 gramm yogurette stecken
sechs gramm joghurt und 3 gramm
erdbeeren wie hoch hättet ihr den
erdbeer und joghurt anteil geschätzt
sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt denn abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips
[Musik]
[Applaus]